ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
日本語失業と第6回開始
飲み会に行きたくないときはどう断ったらいいですか
時々アパートに変えて breath of the wild
をやりたいんだ嘘をついたり例えば5面鏡
は時のオカリナをやりたいんだとか来月ジェットプログラムで悲鳴時に行きます
日本語の勉強がはかどるようにどうすればいいですか飲み会があるときはサボって
ゼルダの伝説やるんじゃなくてちゃんと参加して海をの練習をすること
私はもうちょっとしたら仕事で日本に行きますが見た目はこんな感じなのでちょっと
心配して
ますちなみに身長は178cm 大ジョブだと思いますか
全然問題ない日本人はみんなちーた模様のタンクトップを着て髪をピンクのモヒカン
刈りにしているな
あでも鼻に穴を2つ開けた方がいいしたら完璧クールジャパンについてどう思いますか
格好悪い日本しか取り上げないことをとても不思議に思う
photo 日本なのにクールなんて英語の形容詞を使う理屈がわからない pbs が
万歳アメリカっていう番組を出すみたいな感じでおかしい
最近日本はカタカナを使って新しい単語をどんどん作っている
なんで中国みたいに新しい感じを作らないんですか
中国じゃないからキー
いてと聞いてって同じですかいや違うこっちは音が耳に入る
そしてこっちは自分がその音に集中する心 t 文字が入っているのは心を込めてき
くっていうニュアンスが入っているからだ
まあだから簡単な例を挙げると1クロックは聞くけどさとのアクションは聞く
こう言えばわかるかなもっとも外人ポー
終え行動って何ですか日本に住んでいながら日本について文句をいうこと
日本を能力試験についてご感想教えてください
まったくの時間の無駄だと思うちなみにここでは感想じゃなくて意見の方が自然だ
n one の勉強をしている時に学んだどう下にとって日本はまだ外国っていう感じ
がしますか
もししなけれ
by つしなくなったか教えてくださいいやもうしない
税務署で100万円を取られた時は神秘的な良い国に住んでいるという感覚もすっかり
取られたんだ
バーチャルユーチューバーについてどう思いますか現実のぺー昼夜の作らない限りは
いいと思う私が日本に入って本格的なアニメオタクになれるように私を予防
しにしてくれますか最近仕事で忙しいから実は誰かや東欧かなって考えているんだ
しかしアニメオタクは嫌だから案とは音なんで日本のアーティストはいつも英語を使う
んですか
では質問の中にあったよ音楽家じゃなくてアーチ質だからもうちょっとしたら私は慶応
大学に留学します道元さんのように何かアドバイスありますか
language パートナーじゃなくて友達を作ること文法じゃなくて発音に集中
すること僕のもとかなと付き合わないこと
私は病院と美容院発音の
違いが分かりませんどうしたらいいですか僕の後についてゆっくりいなさい
日本語の勉強諦めます
me